[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone must live with their own minor
handicap I for instance cannot see more
than a vague blur without my glasses on
Peter Brown has to contend with a beard
that slowly threatens to swallow his
face and the protagonist of monochrome
ax can barely move without stumbling the
red scarf boy struggles to clamber up
crates and swing from ropes he stiffly
jumps well short of his target and loses
his balance in precarious situations it
would be easy to pity his clumsiness
except that it's hard to have any
sympathy with the blinding frustration
that defines monochrome ah it took an
hour to admit that monochrome ax was not
ensnaring me as I expected the black and
white aesthetics paint a feeling of
hopelessness that immediately made me
question what made this world so Stark
an omnipresent corporation looms over
the rain-soaked city and without any
people around I felt lost and lonely
it's a great backdrop that tells a story
without any dialogue children's lives
are being threatened and so I had to
carry my younger brother to safety amid
the eerie desolation you run through the
cityscape without direction obstacles
continually obstruct your path so you
must use your wits to continue onward
puzzle design is one of monochrome of
strengths so you can do little more than
pull switches push boxes and perform a
modest jump there are variety of
situations that force you to take
careful stock of your surroundings to
figure out a solution you may have to
catch a swinging rope or douse a barrel
fire all while your brother clings to
your back
[Music]
[Music]
using a helpless family member to
strengthen one's emotional connection is
usually an easy way to invest me in a
journey but in monochrome a-- i only got
annoyed by my siblings uselessness
although you're introduced to your
brother by watching him fly a kite he's
no more than a limp dummy for the rest
of the game why can't he run alongside
you and you must place him in a
spotlight when you need to jump higher
than you could with him on your back
he's such a coward that you can't put
him anywhere else instead of feeling
protective I felt like I was lugging a
worthless lump the baffling relationship
your brother is just a start of
monochrome as problems figure out a way
to complete puzzles is often satisfying
but going through the required motions
is anything bucks long after you know
what you're supposed to do you'll still
be fighting the controls to get the darn
boy to do what he's told even simple
things are incredibly aggravating he may
not be able to jump onto certain ledges
for some reason or he'll hang onto a
switch even as you mash buttons nothing
feels right in monochrome oh and I could
never get over that disconnect there are
also a lot of inconsistencies that zap
away much of this simple joy of solving
a puzzle as nice as the visual design is
I often struggle to determine exactly
what I could interact with and I can't
count how many times I died from falling
too far even if it seemed like I should
be able to make it then there are little
problems such as loading screens
breaking up the flow of your adventuring
or the comical way that you die there's
so many times that I grown from
annoyance or laughs from absurdity that
I struggled to stay invested in what was
unfolding
monochromator nowt to be a massive
disappointment with a distinct art style
and clever puzzles it had so much
potential to be really special
but it's continually undermined by
technical problems so much show that I
struggled to even reach the end the
youthful protagonists of monochrome ah
is incredibly brave and filled with awe
inspiring love and patience but he's so
clumsy that I couldn't overlook his
negative aspects
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]